a lion gives you a different instinctive  fear that is unequal to anything else  they are quite rare you hear them more  often than you see them but just seeing  an adult male in the road in its full  glory was something I thought I would  never see and as we watched him smell  bushes and spray it with its urine it  became clear he was most likely  following a female ahead the lion kept  coming closer and I was hoping really  that he would be away at some point  because remember I am leaning out of the  car window and you can see me zoom out  with the lens but the lion is still  coming and coming and as I am watching  him he's getting bigger you're thinking  I really should be getting in the car  but the photographer side of me is  thinking this is a lifetime opportunity  just  they still  [Music]  [Music]  you